we're now on problem number four from
the from the normal distribution chapter
from ck-12
dot orgs flex book on ap statistics you
can go to their site to download it it's
all for free so problem number four in
it it's at least in my mind pretty good
practice for normal for a standard
normal distribution for a standard
normal distribution place the following
in order from smallest to largest so see
percentage of data below one negative
one okay let's let's draw our standard
normal distribution so a standard normal
distribution is one where the mean is
sorry that drew the standard deviation
is one where the mean mu for mean is
where the mean is equal to zero and the
standard deviation is equal to one so
let me draw that standard normal
distribution C so let me draw the axis
right like that let me see if I can draw
a nice-looking bell curve the bell curve
right there you get the idea and this is
a standard normal distribution so the
mean or you can kind of view the center
point right here it's not skewed this is
the mean is going to be zero right there
and a standard deviation is one so if we
go one standard deviation to the right
that is going to be one if you go to
standard deviations it's going to be two
three standard deviations three just
like that one standard deviation to the
left is going to be minus one two
standard deviations to the left will be
minus two and so on and so forth minus
three will be three standard deviations
left of the standard deviation is one so
let's see if we can answer this question
so what's the percentage of data below
one so the percentage the Part A Part A
that's this stuff right here so
everything below one so it's all of all
of not just that little center portion
it goes keeps going everything below one
right percentage of delete data below
one so this is another situation where
we should use the empirical rule
empirical rule numbers to get more
practice empirical rule or maybe the
better way to remember the empiric
is just the 6895 99.7 rule and then that
I call that a better way because it
essentially gives you the rule these are
just the numbers that you have to
essentially memorize and if you have a
calculator or normal distribution table
you don't have to do this but sometimes
in class or people want you to estimate
percentages and so it's good to do bit
you know you can impress people if you
can do this in your head so let's see if
we can use the empirical rule to answer
this question the area under the bell
curve
all the way up to one or everything to
the left of one so the empirical rule
tells us that this middle area between
one standard deviation to the left and
one standard deviation to the right that
right there is 68% we saw that in the
previous video as well that's what the
empirical rule tells us now if that's
68% we saw in the last video that
everything else combined it all has to
add up to one or two 100% that this
left-hand tail let me draw it a little
bit this part right here plus this part
right here has to add up when you add it
to 68 has to add up to 1 or to 100% so
those two combined are 32 percent 32
plus 68 is 100 now this is symmetrical
these two things are the exact same so
if they add up to 32 this right here is
16 percent and this right here is 16
percent now the question they want to
know the area of everything we do it in
a new color everything less than 1 all
right the percentage of data below 1 so
everything to the left of this point so
it's the 68% it's right there so it's
68% which is this middle area within one
standard deviation plus this left branch
right there
so 68 plus 16% which is what that's
equal to 84% so this part a is 84%
they're going to want us to put it in
order
eventually but it's good to just solve
it that's really the hard part once we
know the numbers ordering is pretty easy
Part B the percentage of data below
minus 1 so minus 1 is right there so
they really just want us to figure out
this area right here the percentage
delete data below minus 1 well that's
going to be 16% we just figured that out
and you could have already known just
without even knowing the empirical just
looking at a normal distribution that
this entire area that part B is a subset
of Part A so it's going to be a smaller
number so if you were just have to order
things you could have made that
intuition but you know it's good to do
practice with the empirical rule now
Part C they want to know what's the mean
well that's the easiest thing the mean
of a standard normal distribution by
definition is zero so number C is zero D
the standard deviation well by
definition the standard deviation for
the standard normal distribution is one
so this is one right here this is easier
than I thought it would be part-ii the
percentage of data above two above two
so they want the percentage of data
above two so we know from the 68 95 99
point seven rule that if we want to know
how much data is within two standard
deviations so let me do it in the new
color so if we're looking for from this
form we do in a more vibrant color green
if we're looking from this point to this
point so it's within two standard
deviations right the standard deviation
here's one if we're looking within two
standard deviations that whole area
right there by the empirical rule is 95%
within two standard deviations this is
95% which tells us that everything else
combined so if you take this yellow
portion right here and this yellow
portion right here so everything beyond
two standard deviations in either
direction that has to be the remainder
so you know everything in the middle was
95 within two standard deviations so
that has to be 5% if you add that tail
and that tail together everything to the
left and right of two standard
deviations well I've made the argument
before everything is symmetrical this
and this are equal so this right here is
two-and-a-half percent and this right
here is also two-and-a-half percent so
they're asking us the percentage of data
above two that's this tail just this
tail right here the percentage of data
more than two standard deviations away
from the mean so that's two and a half
percent doing a darker color two and a
half percent
two and a half percent now they're
asking us is he place the following in
order from smallest to largest so
there's a little bit of ambiguity here
because if they're saying the percentage
of data below one or do they want us to
say what's 84 percent so should we
consider the answer to Part A 84 or
should we consider that they said the
fraction of data below one I would say
0.8 4 so it depends on the how they want
to interpret it same where here the
percentage of data below minus 1 I could
say the answer is 16 16 is the
percentage below minus 1 but the actual
number if I said the fraction of data
below minus 1 I would say 0.16 so this
actually would be very different in how
we order it similarly if you someone
asked me the percentage I'd say oh
that's 2.5 but the actual number is
0.025 that's the actual fraction or the
actual decimal so I mean this is just
ordering numbers so I should fixate on
this too much but let's just say that
they're going with the the decimals so
if we wanted it to do it that way the
they want to do it from smallest to
largest the smallest number we have here
is C right that's a 0 and then the next
smallest is e which is 0.025 then the
next smallest is B which is 0.16 and
then the next one after that is a which
is 0.8 4 and then the largest would be
the standard deviation D so the answer
is C bad and obviously the order would
be different if the answer to this
instead of saying is point 8 4 if you
said it was 84 because they're asking
for the percentage so a little bit of
ambiguity if you had a question like
this on the exam I would clarify that
with the teacher but hopefully you found
this useful